[Musique]
on vous raconte maintenant l'histoire de
victor jeune homme qui buvait tous les
jours des tisanes de kratom le kratom
c'est une plante qui pousse en asie et
santé canada considère que c'est un
produit naturel
c'est sa mère et son ami qui vont vous
raconter son histoire parce que victor
est décédé précisément en raison des
tisanes de crac sommes le 7 décembre
seule la lumière d'un ordinateur est
clair la chambre de victor à callas il
est 17 heures lorsque le téléphone sonne
chez sa mère la salle de victoires
m'appelle pour me dire maman tu les clés
de chez victor parce que il semble est
endormi puis bon je partis on a regardé
par la fenêtre on trouvait qu'il
bougeait pas beaucoup ils ont l'idée
nous et on était un peu inquiet on
ouvert la porte pire
le temps était couché dans son lit est
animé depuis plusieurs heures
probablement son ordinateur est ouvert
et c'est le choc et ses systèmes de mes
victoires
pourquoi pourquoi victoire qu'est ce
qu'est ce que tu as fait qd je vois à
côté du lit un espèce de piché un piège
une de joubert et je me suis dit ça note
ainsi sa tisane
il y avait des projets elle avait des
portes ouvertes pour lui là mais juste
au moment où ça arrive paf on s'endort
on se réveille pour qu'on s'endort en
écoutant les simpson victoire à callas
est tombé dans un piège
le kratom il avait 27 ans personne
autour de lui ne s'est méfié de cette
tisane aux allures inoffensive pour
réglementer et s est populaire sur le
web
et pourtant possiblement toxiques
les corps écrivait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup ses filles meurent
impressionné tout le monde
son fils victor a noirci de nombreux
cahiers comme ceux ci il noté tout
dessiné tout le temps c'est quel père
raconte sa vie avec ses joies et ses
tourments
beaucoup beaucoup de tout réflexion fit
travailler fort pour se sentir bien et
en équilibre
plus tard quelle est ta meilleure amie
c'était un grand artiste un homme
complexe puis est un homme très
travailleur christophe marrouat quenin
victor à cala depuis la fin du
secondaire
il faisait partie du même groupe d'amis
puis le symbole de ici c'est le elle est
le haut pièce qui qui représente peu
partout qui sévit la veuve sauf qui venu
après prayssas abriter love of self
l'amour de soi est devenu pour victor le
symbole de l' équilibre que je cherchais
dans son combat contre l'alcool par
l'été 2012 c'est là que les choses ont
commencé à monter big jeunes dans la
vingtaine on avait des viactive
entouré de ses amis de sa famille victor
surmonte sa dépendance à l'alcool
après une thérapie du moment où il est
sorti de sa maison désintoxication
victor était sobre par choix était il
voulait pas prendre de drogue
il l'est pour retoucher à des choses qui
lui causera une dépendance mais c'est là
qu'on a vu apparaître un peu le le
kratom dans sa ville le kratom et un
arbre qui pousse en asie du sud est
ses feuilles sont utilisées en médecine
traditionnelle ou en automédication
considéré comme une drogue dans
plusieurs pays d'asie
le kratom fait l'objet d'un commerce et
lycées on en retrouve en occident sous
forme de capsules ou en peau de ce plan
clos a été un peu commercialisé comme
étant peut-être un alternative aux
opioïdes médecin de famille marié ève
morin traitent des patients qui
souffrent de dépendance le kratom n'est
généralement pas consommer de façon
récréative
mais plutôt comme un traitement il ya
des gens dont certains patients à moi
que j'ai vu arriver dans mon bureau me
dire notamment et je suis pris sur
l'héroïne j'aimerais m'en sortir avec le
kratom donc un peu faire un traitement
de substitution avec le kratom les
métiers connaissent encore très peu le
kratom sinon qu'à faible dose
il a l'effet d'un stimulant
le problème avec le kratom c'est quand
on dépasse des doses là on développe des
effets du type opioïdes comme on voit
avec la morphine le fentanyl où les
rayons
[Musique]
nous suivons la tresse de victor à cala
jusqu'à l'école de joaillerie de
montréal où il a étudié pendant trois
ans et demi c'est ici qu'il avait trouvé
sa voie sa passion en arrivant et se
préparer sa tisane verte alors que
d'autres se faisait un café moi je
proposais la vie revienne la camomille
mais l elysée n ont même pas saisi sa
mère à cannes ça m'apaise l'esprit clair
ça ça me va c'est ainsi que victor est
sûre et sa mère qui est médecin et tout
le monde autour de lui
verrier de même à 100 dans le ballet
faire quels qu'ils soient sont plus
vertueux qui faisait pas bon de nous
expliquer ma femme actuelle
ça fait comme ça continue présenté sa
commun le même genre de boisson café
selon sa mère il aurait commencé à
consommer du crac hommes pour l'aider à
contrôler son trouble du déficit de
l'attention
j'imagine car il y avait trouvé le 1 bat
lens parfaite et se croyait vraiment
avoir trouvé la formule parfaite pour
l'humanité
on trouve plusieurs sites de vente qui
offre des variétés aux noms exotiques
victor en acheter en ligne et dans une
boutique située sur la rue saint laurent
à montréal
le psychonauts au moment de nos
recherches le kratom et présenté comme
le meilleur vendeur sur son site web
malheureusement moi j'ai vu des gens
dans ma pratique aussi arriver dans mon
bureau on dirait docteur je me suis
acheté du créateur pour mon trouble
d'attention sur moi ça me frise les
oreilles quand j'entends qu'on peut
l'utiliser qu'à ton pour le tibet à 60
préoccupe beaucoup parce qu'on sait
qu'il y en a beaucoup des gens qui ont
été déjà propose-t-on souvent le kratom
pour traiter les troubles de déficit de
l'attention pour le savoir collaborateur
s'est rendu au magasin munie d'une
caméra cachée concentration
[Musique]
rien
après l'avoir mise en garde que le
kratom peut entraîner une dépendance
le vendeur prend ses coordonnées
[Musique]
on aime
il est interdit au canada de vendre des
produits qui contiennent du crac hommes
mais étonnamment il est permis d'en
acheter est donc consommé le piège du
crac hommes c'est que comme les opioïdes
il peut entraîner une dépendance victor
le savait-il louise thibault n'en sais
rien elle cherche des indices dans les
notes de victor kratom été écrit dans sa
liste comme était écrit légumes et écrit
qu est ce qu on voit ça faisait partie
des 202 de ceux de son adhésion à une
marque fais attention avec le 12 âge
j'aurais avantage accueilli les doses
restantes
je crois qu'on parle du créateur
missiles mais victor le feu et il peut
et il sait doses
je les ai jamais vu son éclatante dans
les dernières années parce qu'il était
toujours en proximité de seuil
il y avait clairement besoin de ça pour
pour fonctionner christophe se souvient
d'une fête en particulier la soirée
avançait puis eux
il s'est vraiment mis à avoir des
tremblements qui était qui était très
très anormaux step hausse n'était pas un
tremblement de café c'est vraiment loin
de la victoire ne va pas bien
les tremblements sont de plus en plus
fréquents les pertes de conscience se
multiplient puis travailler à faire
s'ils jouent à son atelier qui était
très concentré et où il s'est mis à
trembler comme s'ils avaient fait une
confusion et là il y en a peu tombée
alors qu'on lui demande de rester à
l'hôpital
la victoire nous nous un plan de les
chercher sa tisane leurs effets tardent
pour les internautes et à l'hôpital
demain et le vraiment à 3 heures du
matin et retour nation ce chrono tourne
à son appartement sa soeur est entré
pour aller chercher sa dose de tisanes
pas ce que dit j'ai besoin de ce domaine
vient ne pourront ne pas accrocher vous
ne pas on n'a pas d'idée voyons ce
rebond semble dans la commune on est
comme aller chercher sa tisane c'est
quand même 27
ça m'étonne encore
au retour pas besoin d'importer le
kratom d'indonésie élan pousse à
montréal
[Musique]
à peine 24 heures après lui avoir dit
qu'il ne vendait plus de crainte hommes
notre collaborateur reçoit un texto du
propriétaire du psychologue qui lui
propose de lui livrer du crac sommes
chez lui c'est le propriétaire en
personne qui fait la livraison
notre collaborateur demande une fois de
plus des renseignements ok parfait au
delà nous avons payé 55 dollars pour 100
g de kratos sur les sachets et il n'y a
aucune indication ni posologie ni mise
en garde
joint au téléphone le propriétaire du
psycho note andré le vert nous dit qu'il
ignorait que le kratom et est si
dangereux où il ya les vins du pareil ça
y est pas droit ouais mais passez vous
que quand ce matin faisait de la
recherche de la main
[Musique]
victor à cala acheter aussi en ligne sur
le site montréalais de madame kratom le
site est fermé aujourd'hui nous avons
joint la compagnie pour discuter de la
vente de crac hommes et du décès de
victor l'avocate de l'entreprise répond
que madame kratom n'a jamais vendu ni
fait la promotion du crac sommes pour la
consommation humaine
pourtant en 2017 dans un échange de
courriels victor leurs écrits que la
dernière variété qui l'a acheté lui a
causé des maux d'estomac
la compagnie lui a alors proposé
d'essayer une autre variété
[Musique]
louise thibault a trouvé dans
l'appartement de son fils près de 3 kg
achetée chez madame kratom les sacs avec
la même mise en garde pas pour la
consommation humaine
santé canada nous dit enquêter sur
l'entreprise
madame kratom tu comprends pas sur le
sac de kratom et écrit ce n'est pas pour
la consommation humaine
alors pour faire prendre pour qui ce
pour meutre pour faire chauffer si c'est
pour eux c'est pour ces pots fer de
lance a cessé pour donner à votre chien
c'est ici mais ça rentre à plein appelé
kg ha au canada et s'est vendu
l'association américaine du crac hommes
estiment le nombre de consommateurs à 15
millions d'américains et 4800 tonnes de
kratom entrerait chaque mois aux etats
unis
il n'existe pas d'estimation semblable
pour le canada depuis 2007
santé canada a effectué des saisies dans
huit magasins et un distributeur qui
vendait illégalement du crac sommes au
pays
pas besoin d'importer d'asie un
horticulteur en fait poussé à montréal
notre collaborateur prend rendez vous
avec lui
[Musique]
françois vincent l'accueille dans son
appartement
[Musique]
bien qu'il soit légal de faire pousser
des plants de créteil chez soi il est
interdit de les vendre
néanmoins jean françois vincent nous
envoie un pour 60 dollars il dit
consommer du crac sommes régulièrement
avec un ami américain
il en ferait le commerce sous forme de
poudre
pour peillon plus haut de plus aucune il
précise qu'il n'est pas facile de
l'importer santé canada n'accorde pas de
permis
ah ouais
jean françois vincent n'a pas voulu nous
donner d'entrevue mais au téléphone il
affirme qu'il est de bonne foi et que sa
production n'est pas une entreprise
commerciale
nous avons parlé à des consommateurs qui
vante les bienfaits du crac hommes pour
soulager des douleurs chroniques
ils ont refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue à l'opposé d'ex consommateurs
témoigne sur facebook de leurs
difficultés à briser leurs dépendances
de cette substance pour la docteur
marième morin le kratom n'est une
solution pour personne ça devrait une
substance étudié réglementé étudié puis
l'on en tire des vraies conclusions mais
en ce moment je trouve que c'est
vraiment la roulette russe un petit peu
le kratom les gens se mettre le doigt
dans l'engrenage mais on ne sait pas
comment ça va finir
puis moi ce que j'ai vu à d'assas a mal
fini parce que toutes les voies lankais
du coroner sur le décès de victor akale
a conclu qu'il est décédé d'une
intoxication involontaire au crac hommes
[Musique]
l'âge des français quittera gicl il est
mort en buvant de la tisane se croyant
l'abri victor à callas et le premier
décés documenté directement lié au crac
hommes on compte deux autres décès au
québec et au moins huit ailleurs au pays
dans ces décès le kratom était mélangé
avec d'autres substances
aux états unis on rapporte une centaine
de décès lié en partie au crac hommes il
y avait de l'information qui manquait
sont les effets du crac sommes sur ce
que ça pouvait faire fi que cette
information le avait manqué à 8 ans on
nous avait manqué à nous à ce moment là
j'ai manqué peut pas être en ce moment à
bâtiment
oh
deux ans plus tard victor à callas est
toujours présent à l'école de joaillerie
des photos
une bague
une lettre
[Musique]
il voulait toujours play pu faire encore
plus plus beau puis faire encore mieux
comme sortis ils sont toujours à la
quête l'anxiété de performance et tout
ça et peut-être que les arrache du crac
hommes subtilement très subtilement
s'est installé pour calmer sa et au prix
de plus en plus d'ampleur a commencé à
détruire à lui couper de plus en plus
les jeunes jusqu'à jeu khalfa mourir
christophe se fait tatouer love of sauf
le symbole créé par son ami quoi c'est
important de l'avoir son encontre
parce que c'est le hockey c'est le king
story battue sauf qu'ils seraient
seraient d'accord avec l'emplacement
[Musique]
malgré tout il ya des scientifiques qui
croient au potentiel du crac hommes pour
traiter notamment la dépendance aux
opioïdes santé canada viennent
d'autoriser des essais cliniques pour
tenter de mesurer le dosage sécuritaire
c'est comme ça que se termine notre
saison d' enquête au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup de votre
fidélité plutôt long de l'année on
attend vos courriers elle vos tuyaux vos
enveloppes brunes revenez-nous en
septembre avec d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]